un mois après la découverte d'un premier
charnier les autorités kenyannes
continuent de retourner la terre rouge
de découvrir des corps plus de 200
victimes dans une quarantaine de fausses
communes ont jusqu'ici été déterrés en
majorité des enfants morts de faim
parfois enterré alors qu'il respirait
encore ça et année je n'ai aucune espoir
17 ancien adepte de la secte de
retrouver les six jeunes enfants de ma
sœur puisqu'ils ont commencé avec les
enfants
et on n'a pas fini de compter les morts
des centaines de personnes manquent
encore à l'appel les dirigeants de la
secte ont incité les disciples à se
laisser mourir de faim pour rencontrer
Jésus il devait commencer par tuer leurs
enfants on les a enfermés dans une hutte
sans eau ni nourriture pendant une
semaine puis on les a enveloppés dans
des draps pour les enterrer certains
sont morts asphyxiés
c'est un autre massacre dit ce
travailleur humanitaire sous le choc qui
parle de crimes contre l'humanité son
ONG et d'autres groupes de défense des
droits humains réclament que le
gouvernement prenne les grands moyens
pour identifier les coupables et
surveiller davantage les 4000 églises du
Kenya et les prédicateurs qui tiennent
des prêches extrémistes voire meurtriers
comme Paul mécanzie
l'ancien chauffeur de taxi devenu
pasteur
semble trouver la situation comique il
est pourtant sur le point d'être accusé
d'incitation au meurtre avec 17
complices
dans le camion qu'il ramène en prison il
dit ne pas comprendre que de suivre
Jésus-Christ soit un crime
a été arrêté une première fois en
2007 il est de nouveau aprèsé en février
dernier quand on le soupçonne d'avoir
tué deux enfants mort de faim et par
suffocation mais il est libéré après
avoir payé une caution de 120 dollars
le président Kenya paye ces mots il y a
eu de la négligence de notre part et de
méthyle cela n'aurait pas dû arriver
nous avons les agences pour intervenir
et je suis contraint de m'excuser car
plus de 200 kényans ont été exhumés ils
autopsie révèlent que plusieurs des
victimes ont été assassinées étranglées
battu où étouffé aussi des organes
manquent sur certains corps ce qui
laisse croire à un trafic d'organes bien
coordonné selon les autorités médicaux
légales ici ce fil en gloire
Radio-Canada Montréal